but what what can the individual do and
just to to summarize the collective do
to stop or slow the decline that clearly
you know you can measure has occurred
first financially be financially strong
have a good income um and balance sheet
income statement and balance sheet think
about how
many months or years years that you
could live if you are um uh if you
didn't have an income the more Financial
Security you have the more
maneuverability you have both to protect
yourself on the downside and to take
advantage of opportunities and to know
how to achieve a balanced portfolio this
is very important I think
financially um and then uh be with
people um your community uh the source
of happiness and psychologists have
studied um that above a basic level uh
income is not a source of Happiness
Community is the highest ranked source
of Happiness so how you work well with
others so I think meaningful work and
meaningful relationships to be
productive and to also have the joy of
those relationships I think is of
Paramount
importance um and then also uh to
realize what the risks are um that's why
I wrote them in in the book um you know
the risks of uh like can you uh well
there are many kind of risks um and do
you understand those risks uh and where
are you and where do you live what are
those risks like to recognize that the
world is domestically and
internationally breaking into different
ideologies and different economic
systems really and that happens state
byst state as well as around the world
and to understand which are the places
that are the best for you and the those
set of circumstances to be aware of
those risks